in July the Federal Trade Commission
fined Facebook for five billion dollars
for violating users privacy this is the
largest fine the FTC has ever levied
against a business in 2012 the
Commission sued Facebook for misleading
consumers about third-party access to
user data and more recently the FTC
found that Facebook was again sharing
data with third-party companies even
though many consumers had requested that
their data remained private the
settlement puts Facebook under more
intense scrutiny from the Commission
here's how the FTC says their rules for
Facebook could protect consumers change
number one third-party apps will find it
harder to get at your data the
settlement will force Facebook to
increase its management of third-party
developers Facebook must now terminate
developer access to user information if
that developer can't justify their need
for that data change number two Facebook
will need your active consent to keep
your facial recognition data the FTC
writes that the company must delete any
existing facial recognition data within
90 days of the order unless the company
obtains user's affirmative consent to
use it on templates in the future change
number three Facebook can't use your
phone number for its advertising
business without your consent as
Facebook ever requested that you add a
phone number for added security it turns
out Facebook may have used it to help
sell ads the new FTC order mandates that
any given number in the guise of
enhanced security may not be shared with
advertisers or other third parties
change number for Facebook must quickly
notify authorities when data has been
compromised the order also mandates that
Facebook increased transparency when
data of 500 or more users has been
compromised Facebook has to deliver
notice within 30 days of the company's
discovery of the incident alongside a
description of steps taken to remediate
the issue the order will not resolve
every issue that consumers may have with
Facebook in a press hearing multiple FTC
representatives stressed that changes
may not be immediately obvious is not
the purpose of this investigation to
vindicate every concern that the world
has about Facebook
we have big national conversations going
on about the company and others like it
right now those are important
conversations they're going to continue
some at the FTC say the restrictions
don't go far enough one commissioner
said that the settlement imposes no
meaningful changes on the systems that
led to these violations
the FTC order is narrowly focused on
Facebook and more limited in scope than
Europe's general data protection
regulation or gdpr that's because the
u.s. doesn't have a comprehensive
privacy protection law FTC officials say
for that reason FTC officials say they
can't do much to limit the kinds of data
Facebook's collected instead they have
to focus on making sure that Facebook
doesn't continue misleading consumers
about how their data is being used in a
press release Facebook said that the
settlement will quote mark a sharper
turn toward privacy on a different scale
than anything we've done in the past